pour en parler nous sommes savais que
michael lambert docteur chercheur
associé au sc eu bon soir médias lambert
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
michel haas carbon qui consultant
international ancien député européen
bonsoir michels carbon qui merci d'être
avec nous les 27 qui débattent donc un
peu cette opportunité d'organiser un
sommet entre l'union européenne et le
président russe vladimir poutine
manifestement la rencontre un bail donne
poutine n'a pas laissé les dirigeants
européens différents les a même inspiré
avant de faire agir vous propose de
réécouter angela merkel il ne suffit pas
que le président américain parle au
président russe je m'en félicite
vivement mais l'union européenne doit
également créer différents formats de
discussions avec moscou
nous devons définir un agenda d'intérêt
stratégique commun par exemple dans le
domaine de la protection du climat
mais bien sûr aussi dans les domaines de
la paix et de la sécurité
c'est sûr que les thèmes sont vastes
michael lambert qu'elles sont et les
différents dossiers sur lesquels le
dialogue peut se renouer précisément
alors pour ce qui est de renouer un
dialogue direct c'est plutôt apaisé les
tensions la priorité principale dans la
mesure où ces derniers temps on a vu une
augmentation des tensions entre l'union
européenne et la russie notamment en
raison du conflit dans le haut-karabagh
donc avec les troupes de maintien de la
paix russes qui ont été envoyées
détention en raison de la biélorussie
puisqu'il ya eu l'interception d'un
avion de fait un blocage aérien de la
part des européens mais un support de
moscou à la biélorussie ce qui empêche
beaucoup de voyages vous avez également
eu le cas de l'expulsion des diplomates
tchèques des diplomates russes en
tchéquie pardon et des diplomates russes
dans les pays baltes ainsi qu'en estonie
donc tous ces éléments là sont
problématiques dans la mesure où ça
donne l'impression d'avoir une union
européenne qui serait anti russe ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas dans la mesure
où vous avez des pays et notamment les
grandes puissances puissance économique
l'allemagne mais également puissance un
militaire et plus grand territoire
maritime au monde la france qui eux ne
partage pas la vision des nouveaux
membres de l'union européenne
et c'est ainsi établir un dialogue entre
une russie grande puissance mais
également les grandes puissances de lui
européenne de manière à pouvoir avancer
ensemble et à des désenclaver un petit
peu cette situation dans la mesure où
pour l'allemagne c'est essentiel pour
pouvoir justifier son projet nord stream
2 et pour la france c'est essentiel pour
avoir un allié solide la russie
notamment pour les projets
internationaux puisque là on parle de
grande puissance donc france et russie
alors la rencontre poutine by day ce
qu'elle a déclenché un déclic pour les
européens en tout cas il ya eu
clairement une réflexion avant de faire
réagir
monsieur carbon qui est écouté ce
commentaire d'un diplomate européen qui
s'est exprimé de façon anonyme dans la
presse belge
l'ue doit avoir la même approche que les
états unis personne ne critique joe
biden quand il rencontre vladimir
poutine il est important de dialoguer
avec les personnes avec qui on n'a pas
le même point de vue alors ça y est les
européens décident de regarder les
choses en face la russie doit être un
partenaire est pas un ennemi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on le réalise maintenant tout
d'un coup en europe
michele scarponi mais n'est-il pas temps
de mettre fin à la guerre froide pid la
deuxième guerre mondiale est terminée
depuis 76 ans et nous sommes toujours au
coeur de la guerre froide nous les
européens en première ligne joe biden
est venu demander le soutien des
européens contre la chine et je crois
que le président français et la
chancelière allemande lui ont dit que il
était probablement d'accord face à la
chine mais que sur le continent européen
il fallait leur laisser la main face à
la russie
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que tout
simplement nous devons enfin discuter
entre l'union européenne et la russie
c'est ça paraît absurde inconcevable
qu'on en soit à se poser cette question
1 mais il est temps il est temps et il
est temps d'arriver à quoi il est temps
d'arriver à un accord sur la sécurité
européenne avec la garantie des
frontières actuelles en échange d'une
aide
d'une politique économique financière à
l'égard de la russie
on doive ans doit mettre en place dans
les prochains mois un pacte d'intérêt
mutuel
il faut ramener la russie dans le camp
européen alors quelle est la tendance
naturellement du fait de la politique
des sanctions américaines européennes à
aller de plus en plus vers la chine donc
il est absurde que l'on que l'on
n'arrive pas à ramener les russes
prennent nous nous appartenons même
continent nous avons pratiquement la
même histoire la halle alors certains
diront pas les mêmes valeurs mais des
valeurs communes en tout cas qu'est ce
qui nous différencie le niveau de nos
démocraties
le stade de nos démocraties voilà bah
ils font parler
donc je pense que dans les prochains
mois il faudra la présidence française
monsieur macro va s'y employer je pense
à la tête de l'union européenne il
faudra créer une stratégie et réunir les
27 ce qui n'est pas facile parce que les
états baltes la pologne la suède sont
vent debout face à la russie bon alors
l'histoire peut expliquer cette position
mais bon nous ne sommes plus en 1940
nous sommes en 2021 donc il faut arriver
à convaincre les 27 d'avoir une
politique commune face à la russie et de
faire confiance à l'allemagne à la
france pour en engager un processus de
discussions de dialogue de négociation
et on arrivera à mettre en place des des
intérêts communs nous avons éteint ses
intérêts de la russie est la russie vit
très mal les sanctions qu'elle subit
nous n'avons aucun intérêt à l'appauvrir
nous savons très bien que quand on a pro
vie en appauvri une grande puissance ça
conduit toujours à la guerre donc il est
temps de revenir sur un un chemin
intelligent et je crois que le président
français la chancelière allemande
lanfains compris à eux de convaincre
leurs partenaires européens de choisir
ce chemin là et au président français
d'organiser au premier semestre 2022
un sommet union européenne-russie en
tout cas le kremlin a réagi positivement
cette proposition on l'a vu michael
lambert ce serait une entente gagnante
gagnante quels sont les intérêts des uns
et des autres à ce réchauffement des
relations bien leur dirais qu'il ya
plusieurs éléments à prendre en compte
de pays à pays est également d' union
européenne et russie de pays à pays
comme on l'a mentionné la transition
énergétique en allemagne notamment avec
l'arrêt des centrales nucléaires amène à
la problématique de nord stream 2 et à
partir de là la nécessité d'avoir plus
de gaz russe qui vient en allemagne on
ne peut pas avoir une politique en
allemagne où d'un côté on plane la
russie et à côté de ça on demande à
avoir plus de gaz importé donc il faut
diminuer ces tensions pour pouvoir
ensuite accentué les relations
économiques pour la france il s'agit de
coopérer avec une grande puissance sur
des dossiers internationaux d'éviter
effectivement que la russie se tourner
exclusivement vers la chine ce qui n'est
dans l'intérêt de personne dans la
mesure où la russie a un intérêt à être
avec l'europe et à être dans une
position entre 2 et ne pas la pousser
exclusivement vers vers la chine est
effectivement un autre élément à prendre
en compte et ça ça viendra peut-être
dans les mois à venir c'est que les
tensions avec la biélorussie amène à des
questions géopolitiques beaucoup plus
profonde
tout comme l'a été le cas en syrie
justement on le remarque notamment avec
la biélorussie une biélorussie qui est
plus proche du kremlin
ça signifie une biélorussie qui a sa
politique alignée sur celle du kremlin
et se pose dès lors la question de la
reconnaissance de la phrase i par la
biélorussie ce qu'a fait la styrie en
2018 et ça pousse justement cette
question de comment est-ce qu'on peut
nouer un dialogue de manière à éviter
d'avoir des positions géopolitiques qui
sont antagonistes
donc en fait ce qu'est cette question de
la phrase i va revenir d'une manière
assez étonnante dans les mois à venir
tout comme elle est venue dans le cas de
la syrie et ça c'est un élément
fondamental notamment pour les services
de renseignement mais c'est ce que tout
le monde attend en fait en toile de fond
après il ya effectivement cette question
d'éviter également d'avoir deux union
européenne donc une union européenne de
l'est qui serait avec les pays baltes ou
encore avec la pologne et la tchéquie
anti russe est une union européenne de
l'ouest qui serait vraiment celle des
grandes puissances
sur le chemin justement michels 46 de
ces deux europes l'est les pro russe et
et j'ose dire les anti russe ccsl chemin
clairement qu'on est en train de prendre
en europe
oui tout à fait l'union européenne a
déjà défini un certain nombre de
secteurs sur lequel il est prêt à
débattre avec la russie sur le climat
sur l'environnement sur la santé sur
l'énergie sur le terrorisme
on doit y ajouter le problème des
frontières
on doit y ajouter le problème de la des
cyber attaques
l e la russie doit cesser ce genre de
politique
moi j'étais très malheureux lorsque
monsieur poutine et monsieur lavrov
croyant bien faire ont humilié joseph
bourrel le ministre affaires étrangères
européens qui étaient venus en
éclaireurs pour préparer le terrain un
dialogue union européenne russie est qui
et qui hélas pris au piège à moscou et
humilié aa n'a servi qu'à être content
contre-productif c'est-à-dire à braquer
les européens encore plus contre la
russie voilà et donc il faut que des
deux côtés en y mettre du sien
monsieur poutine s'il est pris à un
sommet avec les européens
parce que c'est son intérêt sans intérêt
économique et son intérêt politique à
long terme je pense que on va on va
évoluer positivement dans les prochaines
semaines et dans les prochains mois et
en même temps c'est on vit avec cette
chape de plomb de la guerre froide on se
rend pas compte parce que dans la vie de
tous les jours on parle pas que de ça
donc mais nous vivons avec le risque
nucléaire le risque de conflit en un
sens on a eu des conflits larvés au
donbass en syrie et cetera met donc les
des européens vivent avec st donc il est
temps de tourner cette page là cette
page noire de nos relations pour engager
une nouvelle page qu'il faut écrire et
moi je fais confiance au président
macron inquiet qui depuis longtemps
conseiller en cela par monsieur
l'ancien ministre socialiste français
jean pierre chevènement a toujours été
pour un rapprochement avec la russie
on en revient à la thématique gaullienne
un d'une europe qui va de du portugal
jusqu'à la sibérie et donc d'une europe
puissance alors il appartient à l'union
européenne de devenir elle-même une
puissance pour devenir une puissance
elle doit être capables de parler d'égal
à égal avec la russie et donc elle doit
se donner les moyens d'être unis d'abord
face à la russie et ensuite de créer les
conditions de ce que j'appelais impact
d'intérêt mutuel et je crois qu'on y
arrivera la volonté existe donc le
chemin à l'envers quand on entend
effectivement joseph bourrel qui se dit
humiliée repris effectivement par michel
scarbonchi savon qui c'est votre analyse
aussi parce que bon c'est vrai que la
russie le russe ilia iachine c'est aussi
dans l'autre sens on est bien placé pour
le savoir
ici quand même je dirais que c'est
toujours une partie de ping pong c'est
comme ça que j'ai mal à décrire c'est à
dire que quand vous avez détention d'un
côté il ya une réponse de l'autre côté
donc vous humilier quelqu'un vous avez
une réponse
les russes ne sont pas les premiers à
vouloir justement mettre la pression sur
quelqu'un ou à humilier quelqu'un c'est
souvent en réponse à partir de là je
dirais que si on dialogue d'égal à égal
vous avez un dialogue entre grandes
puissances mais également un dialogue
honnête entre des grands pays qui ont
beaucoup à partager et qui ont déjà
beaucoup partagé de par le passé donc je
veux faire cette idée effectivement que
il ya une réponse à une action qui a été
fait mais vous n'avez pas d'une manière
farfelue on va dire quelque chose de
deux violents c'est mon analyse donc il
faut simplement traiter les partenaires
d'égal à égal avec respect merci
beaucoup en tout cas michael lambert
michel scarbonchi et d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour ce
décryptage